that's how the Parliament said about the
nominees for Best Performance by a
supporting actor yeah of course Jean it
was the first time for every one of them
and here we go again right every nominee
for the Best Performance by an actress
in a supporting role is also up for the
first time right and that too has never
happened before the history-making
nominees are Ellen Burstyn in the last
picture show Barbara Harrison who is
Harry Kellerman and why is he saying
those terrible things about me
Cloris Leachman in the last picture show
Margaret Leighton in the go-between Ann
Ann Margaret in carnal knowledge and the
winner is yeah okay
the winner is Cloris Leachman
[Music]
I'm having an amazing life and it isn't
over yet
remember when Ben Johnson said in the
last picture show I fought all my life
against whatever he said and I feel I
fought all my life against cliches and
look at me hopeless cliche I can't thank
anybody I feel that we all have our part
of each other that we've all contributed
and we work together and we're all the
same people and I love you all for for
all the experiences I've had except that
I want to say to Cornelia Williams
Hurlburt my first piano teacher and Rose
Lorenz my dancing teacher in Des Moines
and my father buck Leachman who paid the
bills
[Applause]
and finally my mother whose imagination
and funny sense of humor and almost
water walter mitty life herself led to
all of this and I am deeply honored
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]